hey guys markiplier here I got a lot of
stuff to cover and not a lot of time
first off the extra life charity if you
don't know about it it's where youtubers
and live streamers from all across the
globe are getting together I'm gonna be
live streaming games for 25 hours on
November fifth no that's wrong November
second I can't even talk today so in
order to do that that is gonna encompass
the October and November charity
livestream because this is a huge event
and my goal is bigger than it's ever
been before and fifty thousand dollars
now where I need your help is that right
now there are charity shirts available
the shirts if you missed out on them are
up and ready for sale right down below
there's a link in the description and in
addition to the previous one which is
just a markiplier shirt which I'm not
freaking wearing Wow no all right ok so
in addition to the regular shirt with
the market pliers here stop wow so in
addition to the mark Elias hero's shirt
with the heart on the sleeve there is a
new t-shirt design available which
you'll see um um somewhere else oh yeah
the new teacher design is really cool it
was made by one of my fans I can't
remember than a blue jay on toast that's
who made it um she was nice enough to
give me the design to make and all of
the profits that would normally be made
from these shirts are gonna be donated
straight to this charity the extra life
thing and there's actually a leaderboard
so if we get number one on the
leaderboard which isn't like that
important to me it's kind of important
to me but I mean seriously we guys we
can do a great job because we raised
about forty six thousand dollars last
month and that was just through one day
of t-shirt sales and these sales are
gonna be open from now until Saturday
where I will be doing a precursor live
stream to the charity livestream that
means I'll be life treating both this
saturday for like eight hours or
something and then the next Saturday for
25 hours so there's gonna be a lot of
live streaming going on so stay tuned on
my twitch channel which is also
available down there uh
also this weekend I was over in south
carolina visiting Cindy go to make some
more awesome videos some of you guys
have already seen it but I meant to
mention it here if you look like right
here um there's a small clip it and you
can click there or my face either one do
you want to click the video or you want
to cook my face because I mean it's
really up to you but it's a really cool
video and we got more coming out in the
nearby future I'm so stay tuned for that
also over the weekend there's something
that I wanted to touch on because it's a
pretty important subject to lets players
in general and the stuff on YouTube and
creative stuff going on he's been
following totalbiscuit which I I've been
watching totalbiscuit forever he's one
of my favorite youtubers and up he he he
had a snafu with this game developer and
where they tried to use the YouTube's
copyright system as a means of
censorship and he has a great video
about it I mean it'll obviously the link
will be here if you want to see it I
don't know if I have graphic for it but
it's there you can click there it's
really important message about what we
do here because with let's plays it's a
legal gray area with fair use I mean
fair use in any like domain of music
movies youtube doesn't matter fair use
is a very legal quandary of nightmares
for all the lawyers and stuff but for
the most part the only way that this can
happen and what we do here is because of
fair use and he did a great thing
because he put the profits to the video
that he made which is making rounds and
and raising a lot of awareness to this
pressing issue and hopefully will
address some of the problems and
concerns that lets players have had in
the future but um he's raising that
towards the Electronic Frontier
Foundation which is trying to preserve
rights online rights and there's a
problem with like sis buzz trying to be
passed again if you don't know about
sista you really should it's bad news
for internet openness for everyone so
that was a pretty interesting thing he
handled that beautifully I mean I
watched the video is just completely
well done
so hopefully that'll just do a lot of
good for what's going on in future for
YouTube all right one last thing
obviously we're coming close to a
million subscribers and that's a huge
deal i mean it's probably gonna happen
near the end of this month um if not
early next month it was kind of aiming
towards the 31st but it slowed down a
bit but that's okay because it's still
pretty huge growth no matter what so
sincerely thank you guys so much and I'm
making a very important video um kind of
a look back on how far we've come it's
gonna be very special and I'm very
interest in seeing your responses to it
but most importantly as I come into a
million subscribers um you know part of
what I did back in the rifles too fierce
video is I realized that you know I
don't want to stagnate I want I don't
want to just sit in the same place and I
don't want to be lazy in this because
let's playing right now it's a pretty
easy rhythm for me to do you know i
wanna i want to broaden my reach in and
be bigger and better and better to
myself and improve myself and that's why
you know branching out into the sketch
comedy stuff which is kind of what I
wanted to do before i ever did let's
place is the important to me so I'm your
support in in the videos that I've shown
you has just been absolutely fantastic i
really do appreciate it and i just want
to let you guys know that i I'm so
grateful for it too I'm never gonna stop
doing Let's Plays obviously I'm I'm
always gonna keep that up I'm just
saying on top of that I can do more you
know I can always do more for you guys
and that can always do more for this
channel so I just want you to know that
once we do hit a million I'm not gonna
get lazy it's not gonna be you know a
problem I'm only gonna push myself for
it because you guys have been pushing me
all this time and I really do appreciate
it and everything that you've done to
change my life and given me these
opportunities have not gotten forgotten
and I'm never gonna forget it ever again
like I did before so sincerely just
thank you guys so much for being here
and
up constantly being supported of them
stuff laughs speech impediment will that
ruin that important message so but
sincerely thank you guys so much thank
you so much for watching this weekend
there's a charity livestream for raising
t-shirts you can buy the t-shirts right
now there's down into the scription
click them there's a new one in the old
one and they both have the markiplier
hero's heart on the sleeve so if you
want a new one or if you never got a
chance to the old one buy it now and you
have all week to bite so tell your
friends about it all of the profit goes
straight to the charity I don't make a
penny off of these so that's about it
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you guys for supporting me and as
always I will see you in the next video